The joe rogan experience.
I just don't want to be the
weakest link ever on a film. So,
so that's what you want to do when you're
done with all that? For sure. For sure.
Did you, is that always been an
aspiration or is it something you saw?
I was like a way to do it after.
Oh Man. Got a lot of stuff, you know,
I don't really even like fighting real
honest. Yeah, I'm just good at it.
What don't you like about it?
I don't like the politics behind it.
I don't like the, a martial art
aspect has been taken away from it.
I don't like to um, disrespect to
the sport. Um, guys that are not,
not really training hard.
Um, it don't look the part.
I think professional athletes,
you'll look a certain way. Um,
I really just don't like the youth.
Um,
this generation of fighters at watching
move on TV on youtube and they're going,
they tried to do it.
They don't want to drill repetitious lead.
I don't want to actually put in the work.
Um, why does that affect you though?
It affects me because our sport is also
the fans and the fans actually cultural
who gets to fight and if a guy's going
to talk to enough shit and so I were in
flight suits then this day and age,
that's good enough for a tighter shot
and I think there's disrespectful to
everybody that came before that.
Remember that you had to go tend to know.
Then you get the fucking
call from the UFC,
give Connor want and low ball fund in
the UFC and a 500 record he's going to be
in the UFC. And I just, it's,
it's ways that the sport is
taking the love out of it,
but I just find a way in
dominated my opponents,
taking all their tools away from them,
you know,
Dean Tom and shout out to them and
Duke Roufus or fucking masterminds.
So I take pride in that, take pride and
going in there. They're not getting hit,
um, dominated, knocking people
out, whatever. When you say
you don't like fighting,
you like all those things you don't
like to what other people are doing?
I love training. I don't like what I
don't like the split the sport has become,
so this is an interesting thing to
talk about because a lot of people have
different points of view on that.
And one hand,
a lot of people like the traditional
martial arts approach of respect for your
opponent and just fighting to the best
of your abilities and letting the chips
fall where they may. Whereas
other people say, well listen,
to get people to show up, to get
asses in seats, to get paper view bys,
there's gotta be some drama and
some entertainment value to it.
And that's where someone like Connor
comes into Connor's the only one has done
it though. Yeah. Well Rhonda a little bit.
Rhonda did it a little bit.
Connor is done it the best.
He actually puts in the work he a
son in before he has a sunny day,
but he didn't,
he he his mouth,
his mouth was louder and he's actually
probably the best at it. He's,
he's probably, he's better than
Conor edit columns, very close.
But Connor actually delivers on more than
more of what he said he's going to do
it in shell did.
I would agree.
So if you got to think of anybody who's
brought both worlds together best,
I would have to say Connor,
he knocks a lot of guys.
I would try to call the round,
he's only lost a few fights total.
And even though it's fights,
it was RiskMatch war fighting
the guy switched opponent.
This node is different
weight class. Um, you know,
he's second those risks and
rewards that if you lose,
it's not really that big of a deal.
You know, nobody's going to really,
oh my God dropping down
to the bottom of the pack.
But these other guys that haven't
done it don't have the skills,
ain't putting in the work.
I mean it can kind of really just
where you see the trend, right?
There is a trend right now
at least though, incredibly
disrespectful, very rude.
And you know, you saw what happened
with Colby Covington and you know,
at least be good at Marangu. You know
what I mean? Daddy pressing charges.
I mean that is a Queef.
Well this coward Queef Clinton.
There's a lot of attention being placed
on him though. I mean you, let me see.
It's nicely effective. Let me see how
much attention is being placed in mind.
It is effective in the moment, right? I
mean don't want to go back to this stuff.
It's effective in a moment.
I'm going to tell you why because um,
sometimes that's sometime I sports
is like, you know, nothing going on.
It was like fuck with this is
talking shit. Let me listen to him.
And right there at that point kind
of was around, Rhonda wasn't around.
I wasn't around who is UFC
really projected as a star?
Sage Northcutt had a few bumps.
Paige vanzant had a few bumps.
They tried to push up and Ghana.
But what started to have,
so if you've got this person
that's willing to go crazy,
even though we know it's WWE,
the person is really not getting slammed.
We want to live in that moment anyway.
We want to go for the villain.
Who has he really beat behind Damien Maia?
Well,
what was the other top 15 victory?
Well, the Damien Maia was a big one,
but that was a big one.
But he was one,
but he was unmotivated and he was a guy
that already had his title shots and you
know, he's getting up there in
age. What is really his motivation?
I wrote the book on how to beat Damien
Maia and he didn't even read the book.
He just skim through it because
no part of the book said,
let the Jujitsu guy to fuck you
up and bloody your face cold.
Because Cindy did that by himself.
I didn't do that. You know,
even with my right arm being
messed up. So, um, yeah, he just,
I'm just looking like how
many followers just have,
like, he didn't have a big following
before that. That was his biggest fight.
That was the big, the big coming. I don't
want to this credit, I'm Damien Maia.
Minimize a, Gee, you know, I don't want
to discredit Colby, but you know, for you,
for me, have some people in your resume
have some, you know, I didn't be Derek.
I mean Teryx Hafeni,
Paul Daley, Jordan, me,
and this is before I even got in the UFC.
My first fight was Jay Herron,
who had only been stopped by George Saint
Pierre lost one fight to be in action
that was close and had won every fight
after that. So I never had it easy fight.
All my guys was either former champions
or former contenders are former,
you know, people that were
interim champions and when
you got a list like that,
you should don't get the respect Koscheck
Condon when he [inaudible] you don't
get the respect from who if I caught
them, oh my God can care less what
they have to respect. You
definitely get respect. Watch this.
When you think of Robbie Lawler,
Carlos Condit, right? Right.
They're in a different category as
it were to you that I'm the champion.
I beat both of those guys.
What do you mean by a different category?
I th I see them in a category
then this might just be me.
I see them as in the category is if
you're talking about guys who are going to
enter the hall of fame,
right?
And you think about all
Josh Koscheck and um, oh,
Carlos condit and Robbie Lawler and you
know this guy and Anderson Silva doll,
all those different guys. But it's funny
that I've defeated these guys, right?
You're crazy. You're talking
crazy. I don't think so. No,
you definitely talking crazy.
You're the champ champ. You,
you're acting like people don't
respect you as the champ. They respect,
they respect the people out. Carlos
condit gets more respect or rather log.
It's more,
that's crazy.
Carlos condit gets more respected. Me.
Robbie Lawler gets my respect to me.
But from who though? Sure. Even guys,
even guys that I defeated, like,
you know, um, Stephen Thompson, he drops
and they'll get more respect to me.
I'm not gonna say that, but people are
willing to be like, oh my God. You know,
tell them Dana said, tell them to
get in the cage with Tyrone Woodley.
He didn't say,
hey tire and tell them to get in.
Case with Stephen Thompson
on a seven fight win streak,
knocking everybody fuck out with a really
super word style that took me months
in a fortune, bringing all these fucking
crazy taekwondo, Raymond Daniels,
all these, the best of the
best to train him to beat him.
Like nobody gave me that pass.
I don't know why you concentrate on that.
I know that seems but you are
because you're talking about it.
I'm not concentrating on when he has
these nutty thoughts. I'm telling him,
telling me, I'm telling you this is all
nonsense. This is a wasted, wasted energy.
You think when you think about and that
it doesn't matter to me because my path
is pretty clear what I want to do. I
want to do the best. I want to rent.
I want to be the best waltz with
defending undisputed UFC welterweight.
We in 2007 when that was the shit.
Now Shit is in the middle of wire.
It's kind of middle of last quarter and
they fight and supervise that are bigger
than a world title fight because I know
you as much you don't know you as much
yet and whether whatever.
Look,
Connor is a weird enigma and whatever
reason why that got caught fire the way he
did. It's a weird combination
of personality, results,
skill. It's a lot of,
and Ireland, Ireland is a big factor.
I mean, if Conner was from Nebraska,
I guarantee you
it's not just a big fight country.
The loyalty and the love that those
people have for the people that fight from
Ireland. There's not no, there's
nothing like that. It's, it's a,
it's a weird anomaly,
so he's just this weird aberration and
he gives people almost like false hope of
what's possible because I don't know if
it's possible with a lot of people just,
it just, it's lightening in a bottle
for whatever reason. It worked with him,
but he started it himself and then what
happened? Her company jumper cables. Yeah.
You'll see. Put the
machine behind them. Right?
They definitely put them in the machine.
Behind him.
There was giant hordes of
people flying in from Ireland.
I remember one of some of his
earlier fights I was like,
and I was commenting on and I was saying
this is a guy who was on the undercard
and they're acting like this is
the main event, a paper view.
They've flown from Ireland.
The audience is filled with thousands
of people that flew from Ireland
and now it has does. Even back
then. It was insane when he fell,
he know him back then. You know, it was
funny, somebody while striking coach,
she's like, Conor Mcgregor's is
huge star and da Da da Da. I'm like,
that's where he at first
got into UFC and I'm like,
I don't even know who the fuck
is cute is he was telling,
he was trying to convince me, no,
he's a superstar, he's Dah, Dah, Dah.
And then every time I get a chance I
said, you were right. He wasn't dead.
But there's more of a get ended up being
a superstar and he loves to get their
credit because at that moment I think I
was getting ready to fight Doug and Kim
and he kept home at this Conor McGregor.
So I said, let me look. This is my focus.
Let me look them up because you
obviously got a boner for this dude,
and I looked him up. I'm like,
all right, he's good. I get it,
but let me see and beat a couple people
and then if he can beat Dus, import, Yay.
Then I'm going to give him
his props. Knocking. Talk to
us. Important doesn't pray.
I said, all right, well,
he's 100% legit. He's legit,
but it's what else is going
on? It's so weird. It's,
he's not just legit.
He's also this unbelievable personality
that people are drawn to him.
That's no one can manufacture
that like he's, he's rehearsed it.
He's practiced that. He's looked in
the mirror, he has natural wit. He's,
he's willing to go risky and
say some below the bill shit,
and he does his research. He don't come
to a press conference, just you know,
smoking.
You liked the front row of a comedy show.
He looking into some deep shit and
when you get there you kind of stumble.
So you're right. He has that.
He also has a fight style.
He also has so happened to do
80% of shit he says going to do.
So now he's the fucking Messiah.
But you can't say that the UFC has not
gotten behind you or people don't give
you the respect that you deserve.
That's why you are not in the same
level as you said. You said that it,
him and Connor are super fights.
I'm saying that he has gotten it and I
was saying that he has gotten it and he
has lived up to what he said he's going
to do. And then on top of that, you gotta,
you gotta be able to fight. He can fight
and he has been able to talk. So now,
not only Kinney, generate the paper,
view bys and get people interested.
He's actually going to deliver a knockout
against Josie auto stop as it gets
Eddie Alvarez. And the crazy, you know,
back to back fights with when they did.
Don't you think that you're
in an unusual situation?
First of all because you win the title
by spectacular first round knockout
against Robbie Lawler,
right? Unbelievable knockout.
But then you have the most awkward
and difficult God to defend your title
against Wonderboy.
Thompson is a very unusual opponent and
it's hard to look good against them and
that'll all the people that fought him,
you're the only guy
that put him in danger.
Not once but twice and
the way you fought him.
I've defended the way you fought
him many times. Cause I say, look,
if you look at tactically, if you look
at technique and you look at the, the,
the art of fighting,
that's the way to find them.
If you're a guy like Tyron Woodley, a
powerful punch, it was a great wrestler.
Who's got one real one punch,
knockout ability.
You're not going to open yourself
up to Wonderboy. Exactly.
And don't get picked apart.
You're not going to fight him the way
he wants to fight would you did as you
laid back a lot and people booed a lot
because of that. But when you connected,
you are the one that heard
him in those two fights.
He was the one that was in big trouble
in both of those fights, not you.
Well, his fight was, it was, it was
not for me. I'm never, um, you know,
I got the same thing in the Maya fight,
but at the end of the day,
if someone's attempted to take you
down multiple times, over 20 times,
it's very hard to get in any type
of change. Every time you swing,
they want to go on and eat three shots.
Well, the Maya fight was
tough too because your injury,
but you got to go back and look
at like Anderson Silva dark days.
There was a dark days when Anderson Silva
fought Damien Maia where nobody wants
to have anything to do with them after
that fight. And Anderson Silva fought. Um,
when he fought there, there's,
there's several fights where, um,
he had just boring results and people
weren't interested in him fighting
anymore. One spectacular
knockout and everybody's back
got it.
It again.
And then one spectacular knock out to
get the belt and then everybody slowly
forget about it moments later. Cause
at the time Stephen Thompson said, Nah,
where the fight Robbie and I think
he's going to win anyway and that Ah,
and then he think I'm supposed to be just
so graciously like God that's fighting
the honor. And the na you wanted to
fight Robbie, right? You say rob,
who's going to win?
You say you personally prefer to write
fight rob because I'd been waiting around
even though that wasn't the
case. So you said this, uh,
so don't think that I'm just going to
give you my spotlight and say, hey,
you know what the others do this. No.
If I'm seeing the table being set,
I know there's Nate disease out there.
Nikki is out there.
George Saint Pierre is Michael Bay's
means guys that have that name,
they have that status
that I'm trying to get to.
Those are the guys I wanna fight.
I want to knock those guys now because
now I can continue to intro myself up
fighting him. Well, he's trying to
get the same thing I'm trying to get.
Why the hell am I going to pull
you up with me if that's the fight?
They wanted me to fight one on one.
They never offered me to fight.
He said something. Then I think the
UFC thought I wouldn't take the fights.
The first time they offered
me the fight accepted it.
So when all these people are like,
oh my God,
you don't want to fight trying to pick
his fights, he's just got the belt.
I'm like, Ooh man, you,
it's not, I'm talking about
too many people saying things that
you're responding to that are,
that are irrelevant.
I think it's the two people that that are
in the organization. I got to, you know,
you're dealing with people that I
don't deal with them in that regard,
but as far as like people
that are analysts and experts,
as far as like the social media,
like I really don't read social media.
I post because I want to post and I'll
leave it alone. So that's why I say that.
I'm not saying without saying who it is.
I'm not saying that the fans are making
me feel some type of way. Cause my,
my path is clear. I want to be the
greatest welterweight of all time.
[inaudible].